Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a lot of time
on this next story, but I do want to mention
that what were originally subtler attacks on
Dr. Anthony Fauci, the head infectious disease
doctor in the United States when Trump was
president, Trump started having disagreements
with Dr. Anthony Fauci about all things
COVID. And it started a little bit of like an
under belly of people online and others starting
to attack Dr. Fauci. This has now gone fully
mainstream within the Republican Party. Senator
Rand Paul, one of the figures that has been very
publicly attacking Dr. Fauci and most recently,
Senator Ted Cruz, remember Cancun Cruz. He now
has said that Dr. Fauci should be prosecuted,
prosecuted. Dr. Fauci was asked about this.
I don't know if it's that the the pandemic
itself has him sick of all this nonsense. I
don't know if it's, you know, he's an 80 year
old guy. Maybe he's close to retirement and
he just doesn't care anymore. But he did
not pull any punches here on Ted Cruz and
good for Dr. Fauci. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: So anybody who spins, lies and
threatens and all that theater that goes on with
some of the investigations and the congressional
committees and the Rand Paul's and all that other
nonsense, that's noise, Margaret. That's noise.
I know what my job is,
Speaker 3: Senator Cruz told the
attorney general. You should be prosecuted.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I have to laugh at that.
I should be prosecuted. What
happened on January six? Senator, how
Speaker 3: do you think that this is about
making you a scapegoat to deflect course,
President Trump?
Speaker 4: Of course you
have to be asleep, not to figure that one out.
Speaker 3: Well, there are a lot of Republican
senators taking aim at this. I mean, that's OK.
Speaker 4: I'm just going to do my job and
I'm going to be saving lives
and they're going to be lying.
Speaker 3: It seems another layer of danger to
play politics around matters of life and death.
Speaker 4: Right, exactly, exactly. And
to me, that's that's unbelievably bad.
Because all I want to do is save people's lives.
I mean, anybody who's looking at this carefully
realizes that there's a distinct anti-science
flavor to this. So if they get up and criticize
science, nobody's going to know what they're
talking about. But if they get up and really aim
their bullets at Tony Fauci, well, people could
recognize there's a person there. So it's easy to
criticize, but they're really criticizing science.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And you know, there are people
who are reacting to this by saying, Oh, it's it's
inappropriate. Imagine people carrying now about
what's appropriate. It's inappropriate for a
medical official to criticize a senator. Well,
is it appropriate for senators to attack a public
health official all along dating back to the Trump
era? Because what he said conflicted with the
non-science blabber of Trump because Trump wanted
to make everything seem less serious. And if you
listen to what Dr. Fauci was saying, you would you
would have no other conclusion than wow. If Dr.
Fauci is saying this, this must be pretty serious.
While Trump said our 15 cases are soon going
to be zero, maybe one of the dumbest statements
ever made by a president in history. Give me a
break now they care about what's appropriate. So
good for Dr. Fauci. Good for Dr. Fauci. You
know, we don't know how long he's going to want
to keep working at this point. He has been doing
this for decades and is 80. And if I were him,
I would be very sick of what's going on. But he
seems determined to keep doing what he can to save
lives. And of course, he should be commended for
that. But the way in which people like Ted Cruz
are attacking him is absolutely disgusting. And
he is. It seems to be as sick of it as I would be,
at least. We'll have more clips from this
interview on her Instagram. You can find
The David Pakman Show Instagram at David Pakman
show. Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.